es re disfrute de la jardinería cada
girasol que él riega requiere de 0.7
litros de agua y cada azucena que riega
requiere de 0.5 litros de agua ésta
tiene un total de 11 litros de agua para
estas plantas en la siguiente
desigualdad ese representa el número de
girasoles y l representa el número de
azucenas que es la puede regar veamos si
tiene lógica esta desigualdad
tenemos que 0.7 multiplica el número de
girasoles que se tienen por lo que esta
sección de aquí no representa el total
de litros de agua necesarios para regar
los girasoles
y de igual manera tenemos que este
término de aquí nos representa la
cantidad de agua necesaria para regar a
las azucenas
nos dicen que tiene un total de 11
litros así que todo esto la suma de todo
esto tiene que ser menor o igual a 11
riega diez de sus cenas cuántos
girasoles podrá regar como máximo con lo
que le sobra de agua
bueno si la riega 10 a sus cenas quiere
decir que el número de a sus cenas
qué es el l va a ser igual a 10 bueno
nos queda que hay 0.7 multiplicando el
número de girasoles los girasoles que
puede regar más el número de litros que
ya usó para regar a las azucenas
si él es igual a 10 y se requiere medio
litro por cada a su cena tenemos punto 5
por 10 va a ser igual a 5 ya ocupó 5
litros de agua para regalarlas a sus
cenas y esto tiene que ser menor o igual
a 11
así que podemos tratar de dejar solita a
la s en este lado izquierdo de la
desigualdad vamos a hacerlo lo primero
que hay que hacer es restar este 5 de
aquí en ambos lados de la desigualdad
por lo que tenemos menos 5 aquí y menos
5 de este otro lado
del lado izquierdo nos queda este 0.7
por s y el 55 se cancela queda hacer de
este lado sólo nos queda el 0.7 por s y
de este otro lado de la desigualdad nos
queda que 11 menos 56 y ahora vamos a
dividir ambos lados entre 0.7 y esto no
nos afecta la desigualdad porque estamos
dividiendo entre un número positivo 0.7
entre 0.7 se van y me queda solita la s
esto es menor o igual a 6 entre 0.7
vamos a tratar de simplificar esto voy a
escribirlo aquí y voy a escribir todo
como fracciones
6 entre 0.7 es igual a 6 entre
7 entre 10 y esto a su vez es igual a 6
por 10 entre 7
que es igual a 60 séptimos
60 séptimos 60 entre 7 va a ser igual a
8 y 4 séptimos así que esta es el número
de girasoles que pueden regar tiene que
ser menor o igual a 8 enteros 4 séptimos
pero suponemos que él va a regar plantas
completas no fracciones de plantas así
que sí ese tiene que ser menor o igual a
8 y 4 séptimos cuántos girasoles podrá
regar máximo con lo que le sobra de agua
pues podemos decir que máximo él puede
regar 8 girasoles
no puede regar una fracción de la planta
tiene que regar una planta completa por
lo que solo podrá regar 8 girasoles que
es la cantidad entera máxima que podemos
tener con estos cálculos y que cumplen
con esta desigualdad de que ese sea
menor o igual que 8 enteros 4 séptimos